[Music]
the most
important thing to remember to keep your
trees fresh
is to get them into a water stand as
quickly as possible
after you leave our store we will
actually make a
fresh cut on the bottom of the tree so
that it opens it up to be able to suck
up water quicker
you want to use a tree preservative
like this one right here to put in the
water
so that it'll keep it fresher longer
keep it absorbing water longer
do not let allow the stand to go dry
with water
you want to make sure and keep watering
at all times so that the
tree can be absorbing it as much as
possible these
premium trees like the noble fur here
these hold their needles for quite a
while they will
they should definitely hold them through
the christmas and
normally into new year's now these
nordman fur
have a little darker flatter needle
than the noble fur that we just looked
at and on the underside they have
kind of a grayish silver color that
makes it kind of a two-tone
tree the douglas fir is
our least expensive tree it's the most
fragrant tree that gives off the most
smell
but it is probably the the one that will
dry out the quickest because it's got a
smaller
thinner needle as long as you provide it
with good water and it's taking up water
then it should last close to
you know shortly after christmas or a
little bit beyond
it's very important to keep them as
fresh as possible because once they dry
out
they become very dry and brittle and
can actually become a fire hazard if you
have a very dry tree in your indoors
if you have pets or small children
you want to really either raise your
tree up on like a table
you don't want to have them around too
closely where you can break things and
be dangerous
for the last last few years there has
been a shortage of christmas trees a lot
of the growers have
been running out quickly
last year we ran out very quickly we did
buy more trees this year
and but they're going very very fast to
get the best selection you want to come
down and buy your tree
as soon as possible